Rangers patrol corrupt national park in
southwestern Cameroon practically
round-the-clock it's their job to
protect the surviving animals from
poachers people have been living in this
area for centuries hunting for food has
a long tradition here only Benton
Minnesota House that we feel very very
happy and we don't have anything already
we'll all be happy that one tradition
year diversey the gold grand not eating
empty food but now many animals in
Cameroon are threatened with extinction
Rangers and conservationists use camera
traps to record the dwindling
populations in corrupt national park in
particular primates like chimpanzees and
drill monkeys are endangered they are
hunted for food or sold illegally often
the only source of income for people
living in and around the National Park
but in air at things are different the
head of the National Park has come to
visit he's given a ceremonial welcome
people here used to be involved in the
illegal bushmeat trade but now the
villagers cooperate with the park
rangers the inhabitants benefit from
sticking to conservation rules solar
power for instance was introduced to the
village in return this time they can the
local people become the center of
conservation efforts so for the first
time we were consulted at every stages
we're hooked up became convinced of the
fact that we could have different ways
of earning a living inside the national
park like former hunter john expo for
example avril lavigne hunting have
become increasingly strenuous for the 59
year old nowadays he cultivates bananas
cocoa beans and mangoes the
conservationist would like to persuade
more hunters to follow his example his
family today enjoys a higher standard
than they did in the past leaving it
where I said I'm a thousand francs I
think I could plant even more about it
because it's very easy money that's her
the harvesting is very easy maybe you
just break the cocoa beans lay them out
to dry in the Sun and then sell them I
laid it's not as hard as hunting I used
to have a lot of problems with that have
an auto oiler in the community hall the
head of the village announces a ban on
hunting all family heads have agreed to
the measures and the sanctions attached
ten men are handing over their guns to
the conservationists the village is
getting 10 motorcycles in exchange the
first men are already receiving driving
lessons there used to be bushmeat
hunters now they will be able to earn
their living as couriers or taxi drivers
this track through the rainforest is
quite new a bridge is under construction
to on foot it takes six hours to reach
the next village and sometimes when the
river rises it's impossible better
access will enable people to sell their
goods at market but ja neck bow is
hoping the route through the forest will
remain just a dirt track he fears that a
proper Road could attract illegal
loggers run over horrible virus is a
friend of mine if this forest disappears
I might even die myself I can also
disappear the conservation program has
shown inhabitants that environmental
protection can help then thrive to
you